he literally said that like hey when you
go to church you better kick me back 10
because whatever you made is already
mine to begin with yeah Jesus sounds
like a pin you better give him a tempest
yeah
the big yeah The Vig
[Music]
this article right here is submitted by
one of our loyal patrons Antonio Lopez
who hey I like that guy Antonio every
week Yep this is actually about a Mormon
who left Wall Street to work for
quote-unquote charity but ends up
blowing the whistle on what he says is
his Church's clandestine hedge fund so
he's talking about the Church of Jesus
Christ of Latter-day Saints and he was a
former manager at the church's
investment firm the church has an
investment firm triggers make money whoa
churches make real good money even the
small Church plants yeah his name is
David Nielsen he even says that during
his nine years managing money at the
church firm the value of its Investments
ballooned past a hundred billion dollars
billion what the [__] we gotta get a
church you guys which makes it the
largest Treasurer held by any religious
Fund in America oh so Mormons are the
richest holy [__] but he said instead of
spending that money to do good he
alleges it was used in ways that bent
the law and broke his faith I thought I
was going to work for a charity I
thought that's what my skills were going
to do was help build the charity and do
good things and the funds were never
used for that it was really clandestine
hedge fund those funds weren't used the
way that they were appropriated to be
used once the money went in it didn't go
out so basically they're what's that
word where everybody's supposed to give
like 10 of your tithing time yeah
everybody and you know like churches
like of this magnitude kind of like the
mega churches they have
[__] tons of fun they have 17 million
members oh dude those and the hardcore
ones they they do auto time yeah whoa no
I think my family did that where like
you're like the paycheck they get from
work before they see the money it gets
automatically deducted to the church
like they have your [__] routing
number wait wait is it is it from your
paycheck or is it from your bank from
your paycheck they do it from a paycheck
like a freaking tax because what time is
supposed to be it's everything you make
ten percent of that every time so they'd
look at it like oh here's what I made
for this that's a crazy rule isn't it
ten percent go straight to church yeah I
feel like there's so so much human
manipulation and everything like how did
we come up with a 10 it's a good number
Jesus said it apparently yeah he said in
the New Testament he literally said that
like hey when you go to church you
better kick me back 10 because whatever
you made is already mine to begin with
yeah
is like 10 or some [__] no I guess it's
like the yeah it's Gonna Keep dripping
includes interest when you don't pay it
right passive income baby Jesus is all
about that passive income that's what
he's about I always thought that was so
funny where's my money [__]
when I go to church and I drop like a 20
or 100 like in the basket River I feel
pretty good I'm like okay cool I hope
this goes through a good cause bro no
it's it's like I've been talking like
years of Auto deductions from millions
of people 17 million yeah so every year
10 bucks each that's already 170 million
in a year or [__] this church collects
an estimated seven billion dollars in
contributions from its tax-free by the
way because it's the church this is a
church church expects it attacks them a
little bit so the church expects members
to contribute about 10 of their income a
practice known as tithing tithing is
what's used to build buildings this was
used to pay light bills tightening is
what's used to operate some of the
church's programs whatever's left over
about a billion dollars or so is put
into a reserve fund at Ensign Peak which
is the name of this particular
establishment and invested because
Ensign Peak is registered as a
non-profit it all grows tax-free
he says that since it was created in 97
the reserve fund has swelled Beyond 100
billion dollars twice the size of
Harvard's endowment or the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation
wait twice the size of the bill in
Melinda Gates Foundation yeah oh my God
here's the thing though
he says you could even saw you know a
lot of big problems with 100 billion
dollars right I thought we were going to
pretty much all of them and they don't
have to clean it that's crazy but when
asked did any of your former bosses
explain how the money was going to be
used one day he says the answer was
always quote the second coming and it's
a bit tongue-in-cheek but deep down I
think a lot of employees really did
believe that so basically it's all just
meant to be saved until Jesus Walks
again the second coming where things
like everything gets flipped over and
then now they have you know Reserve
money to rebuild what is supposed to
happen when Jesus comes back I think the
world's supposed to end is that yeah
there's like a long list there's that
Seth Rogen movie about it oh yeah yeah
this is the end so like that was it
right that was just a really demented
version of that yeah we'll go up to
heaven you can say that it depends like
they don't some Bibles don't have the
Rapture segment oh so that's what the
Rapture is well the Rapture is that
people just magically are gone that go
to heaven and then all the bad stuff the
senators stay on Earth they're supposed
to be a horn a horn I think
oh yeah that's my man that's what I
meant is that the same thing no no you
know there's the politicians I always
want to [__] tax the billionaires
yeah you should attack the [__]
churches the churches are supposed to
try to help out anyways they can't it's
unconstitutional is it though separation
of church this world got 100 billion
dollars that's why I think Scientology
is the most genius thing I think it's so
funny that like some dude probably was
like all right we're just gonna say this
is a church yeah and we're gonna make it
about the most ridiculous premises but
as far as like their Church goes like at
least they're doing therapy or some [__]
don't they do their bunch of therapies
is that called brainwashing should we
start whatever but what is it what is I
don't know we should start a church okay
Google how to start church we could yeah
let's let's start Church Church speed
the Church of believing in the bettering
of lies of others that's pretty solid
hey that's kind of gangster
in any means necessary the Church of
nine percent tithing Chapel De Los
Chavez Velasquez what if we did the
Church of hustle culture dude and it's
all about hustle Culture Rising grind
you know what I mean like
self-development Fitness we could do bro
that's easy it's just the red pill
actually yeah everybody loves garyvee
everybody else [__] Alex hermosi but
we make a church version of that to get
people to hustle yeah Church of hustle
and they get us to pay ten thousand ten
percent of whatever they make because
isn't it really difficult to have a
church now that's new like you just
can't do that right because it don't you
have to like survive cult status to
attain Church status yeah you got to go
past Waco yeah how do you survive cold
that's the thing it takes freaking
forever how long does it take not all of
them die oh yeah yeah so if we don't
kill our members we're good
it's crazy publicly church leaders
called it a rainy day fund but in 2013
uh Nielsen says one of his bosses shared
this document at a meeting that showed
1.4 billion dollars from the fund went
to a all being built on land owned by
the church and 600 million dollars was
used to prop up a for-profit
church-owned insurance company called
beneficial life I thought you say
Adriana's oh yeah 600 million dollar
Adriana this year
killing it dude that's how they could be
on the buses
who are his bosses are these bosses like
pastors or they're like CEOs Cardinals
yeah like Horrors [__] British people
they gotta be businessmen with some sort
of religious background they call it a
rainy day phone I should make a rain fun
yeah exactly when the world ends you
need a place for people to go which is a
giant mall right and what if you die you
need insurance to cover your death you
know what's funny is like if they were
biblically accurate about this like end
times money
doesn't the bible say that at some point
you can't buy or sell unless you have
the mark of the beast anyways what does
that mean you would know by yourself
yeah anything good service oh it's
bartering yeah according to the the last
age is that like they wipe out all
ability to have Financial transactions
unless you get the mark of the beast
which is what they're calling the
digital like chip oh interesting I think
that's a joke so it's not face tattoos I
think that's a good thing
so that it seems kind of backwards that
like it doesn't make sense yeah it seems
like contradicting with her I think you
should send a letter 11 was like hey I
think you've been misappropriating your
funds I think you should donate to us I
have this other church that is for the
benefit of other people oh wow he talks
about he hit his breaking point in 2018
after a website called Mormon leaks
linked church members to companies that
existed only on paper those shell
companies held billions of dollars in
stocks and bonds what nobody knew
outside Church leadership was those
assets were actually controlled by
enzyme Peak Nielsen says the firm called
an emergency meeting
code these entities were to hide the
assets from the members the chief
investment officer said that if we were
to change and start reporting the
Securities in our own name it would
bring undue attention to the firm and
that that attention would be potentially
damaging and after the meeting I went
and confronted him what do you mean
potentially damaging and he said Dave
we're going to lose our tax exempt
status yeah that's laundering right yeah
oh that's hot dude
wow so they're fully aware the
government's really strict on non-profit
stuff because seniors fight back we have
to track every single expense and it can
only be used in very certain categories
and they find that we misuse like one
dollar we lose our tax exam status but
this guy Jesus imagine that if if Ron
has to collect receipts of every senior
that fought back
[Laughter]
in the obituary
I can't believe you made that joke
[Music]